au milieu du massif des carapatte une
citadelle vertigineuse entouré de
profondes forêts abritent depuis des
siècles une terrible dynastie de ses
bons mots olemps ii wolfensberger karine
mer et tu la connaissais même pas top
prépare toi on y va partir dans un
royaume plein de loups moi je te le dis
tout de suite à enseigne
l'établissement n'accepte pas les
clients comment dire à poil bizarre
quand même de penser à toi tu viens le
sommet pierre davot la peluche je vous
demande de reposer doucement montmagny
kelopuro scarlett a prévenu un vol
fédérer les amis vous venez pour le
festival de cartes je suppose c'est toi
le festival de cannes car match les
filles je vous présente l'aude victor
olten bern lapin de bale maintenant
comme le pt comme les derniers chérie
fais tes valises on se casse qui alloue
un jour ou l'autre
pendant que tu joues à devenir un vrai
loup moi je dors à l'ours soulignent les
musique evous captain commando de
libération de tous les conflits
vous pouvez nous suivre dans la forêt
vous est en grand danger
oh non
regardes tu vas voir c'est de montrer un
truc de l'eau jusqu'aux jeux comprend
pas normalement la lune apparaît grand
quand on fait ça craque
d'habitude ça marche